every day since this past weekend Matt
Matt ox oi has taken the subway to
Taksim Square in downtown Istanbul the
square has become the center of a
protest movement that's meanwhile spread
to cities across Turkey the 73-year old
ox oi is a longtime leftist and activist
in the early 1980s he was forced to
leave Turkey for Germany after the
military coup as you can see it's like a
public festival here and there are all
sorts of people here young and old women
with head scarves and women without them
how can add one say these people here
are nothing but extremists that's just a
smear tactic nothing but slander ox oy
also bears a personal grudge against the
Prime Minister he's turkeys best known
sculptor his sculpture of the goddess
Sibley adorns Istanbul's banking
district several years ago the city of
cars near the Armenian border
commissioned him to create a 35-metre
high statue of humanity but then Erewhon
paid the city a visit yes in a part of
the country that suffered from constant
war I wanted to build a monument to
understanding it was two people facing
one another and visible from afar when
it was finished the two figures were
going to join into one I had all the
necessary permits but one day the Prime
Minister came for a visit he declared
the statue a freak and ordered it
demolished dr. Danzer
many Istanbul residents say Taksim
Square is another example of government
arbitrariness and abuse city authorities
had planned to redevelop the square
hundreds of trees were to be felled to
make way for the restoration of a
military barracks from the Ottoman era
which would house a shopping mall the
protests began a week ago as a sit-in
jihan basil a human rights activist was
there from the start exuma the
government is redeveloping the last of
our old original districts and squares
in this city they're doing whatever they
want that's what we're protesting here
but meanwhile this protest is also about
more the government is trying to force
us to adopt their way of life so this is
also a struggle for democracy Candido
Lucius nagar OOP optimo Derby democracy
popular my service the trees at Taksim
Square have been saved for now but just
a few meters away work continues on what
critics say is another example of
ruthless development an entire city
district is being torn down to make way
for new luxury buildings the residence
most of them Kurds in Roma were forced
to move opponents of the project say
Prime Minister Erewhon is also directly
involved his son in law's company is
profiting from the project dissonance
opinion just imagine you wake up one
morning and your house and your entire
district where you were born and raised
has been sold to a building company
where else could something like that
happen but here citizen even if it is
Aaron Deborah Java but the Turkish
economy has been booming under air
dhawan that's also why he still has many
supporters I work here I think we're
improving the district
who can't get a boner but these
authoritarian tactics will turn the
entire district into a powder keg but
look at what the protesters are doing
there have been fires everywhere and it
broke the windows of my friends shop
over there traces of this violence are
everywhere around Taksim Square but like
matt mattox oy and his friends most of
the demonstrators want peaceful protests
right now they're preparing for another
onslaught of water hoses and tear gas on
the part of the police more than 1,000
people have been injured and to have
died in the protests across the country
that has only strengthened the activists
resolve George we want a government
that's environmentally responsible and
that follows the law a government that
helps overcome injustice and that allows
us more freedom and greater rights
Cockerham a sit-in to say the trees has
become a struggle for greater democracy
in Turkey as darkness falls another
restless night begins